is it something about their the way they
present themselves to fans I know for
you you've always talked about your not
about idol worship you really wanted to
turn a lot of your having fan clubs in
to volunteer organizations they already
are they have like I have donated my
body probably I was the first actor in
India I don't know where else to donate
body for science and I did it not not to
show off but so that to show away and so
that now there are many body donors in
India and when I say body donor we don't
have to go into the gory details of
autopsy alone he could harvest body
parts which could be useful in in a
country whether a lot of cool people can
can't afford to buy body parts
transplants and so many people who have
to live to take care of a family so and
this was a this a signatory for this
donation was my daughter and so it made
a nice impact on my fans and they have
already donated two hundred thousand
eyes willed living people so there are
two hundred thousand eyes one day or
rather which are going to be used for
that that's probably 400,000 people can
see what is it about idol worship that's
negative to you and in terms of being
put on a pedestal we have been put on a
pedestal is good but even in Rome you
had these great warriors walking in to
be be feted and there's always an old
man sitting right behind him in the in
the chariot reminding him remember your
mortal it comes from the time much
before Christ so this I think there's
this little boys and me which keeps
telling me that let's not keep them
anymore I mean nothing is worthy of
worship that's my feeling nothing is
worthy of worship
can be used it can be harnessed can be
loved but that's my feeling I mean might
sound like I'm too rational but that's
all I am well there's an American saying
that is on remember the people that you
pass on the way up because they can be
the same that you see on the way down
and it's a it's a reminder of humility I
think yeah but that's one part that's
only about yourself that since you're
gonna go up and down you better know the
steps but what I am talking about is
something else I'm talking about
generally I believe nothing is worthy of
worship it should be respected it can be
venerated it can be loved that that's
that's my problem with the I mean daya
fication
you